so I think you probably all are thinking
the same thing you have a burning
question I felt like I wouldn't be able
to do the rest of my speaking tour
without first addressing the burning
question and I got bombarded on Twitter
today everyone has the same basic
question right and that is have I tasted
haggis and the answer is no I'm too
scared because I made the mistake of
reading how it's made first before
tasting it I've been told you're
supposed to do it the other way around
because it's a lot less scary I'm trying
to build up the courage and I I've been
told that the best way to do this is in
a burger I don't know if that's actually
true No
okay there's a big disagreement in the
room okay so on the count of three all
those in favor
haggis burger nobody okay
haggis for breakfast okay
[Applause]
are there other formulations I should
try I guess are toast
very good
[Music]
how about a corporate sponsored haggis
that is pretending to be an open Hajus
and was launched this morning okay so
let's talk about the elephant in the
room and the elephant in the room is
Libre you probably all heard that this
morning Facebook announced their
cryptocurrency Libre and you know
whatever the price of Bitcoin goes down
I get calls from friends and family and
they call me up and they go are you ok
this time I actually got a call from a
friend's mom to ask me if I'm okay and
the price hasn't even dropped but just
the fact of Facebook launched the
cryptocurrency led to the holding in
there is everything ok
do we need to airlift you out of Europe
I'm ok I'm ok I asked Lee talks about
this probably three years ago that one
day we would see this happen and today's
the day right so it's now happening it's
happening but what it exactly happens
and what can we talk about today so what
happened was this morning Facebook
released a white paper not a
cryptocurrency not a network not a
currency not a project not an
application a white paper and
everybody's freaking out because they
wrote a white paper now there's a long
road to go between white paper and
production network available to 2
billion users wrapped in you know candy
colored farmville interface or whatever
they're going to do with it next but
they release the white paper and
everybody got really excited so how many
here have read the white paper Oh
excellent quite a few I did a brief skim
I'll be honest with you I
a brief skim it's been a busy day I got
a whole bunch of calls from journalists
who wanted to talk about it and I am NOT
ready to talk about it because this is
gonna take a lot more study I'm not
going to talk too much about the
technology today because we don't really
know how it's gonna play out but I do
want to talk about what changed and what
changed is everything everything changed
this morning something we've been
predicting for more than three years
just happens and it changes everything
and it changes everything whether or not
Facebook is able to get this into
production the mere fact that this white
paper was dropped has now set the bar
they dropped the gauntlet Silicon Valley
is coming for banking in a big way and
we predicted this was gonna happen a lot
of people in the space predicted this
was gonna happen
and a lot of people thought it was gonna
be Amazon first but turns out it was
Facebook which is much much worse than
anyone had imagined possible
all right so about the white paper if
you've if you've taken a look this is a
collaboration of about I think that was
about 30 names on the top of the white
paper I have a feeling that the way this
was played out within Facebook some
people are saying this was a more than
one year effort I have a feeling of what
they did was they created this incubator
sandbox Innovation Lab environments
where they took 3040 really bright
people they locked them in the room and
they slid pizzas under the door for a
year and out came a white paper and and
what that white paper represents is
actually very impressive it's very
impressive in terms of the technology
vision so what they were able to do
these people are very serious about this
and very well informed about what we're
doing in the cryptocurrency blockchain
space they cherry picked some of the
best features of the best crypto
currencies the state of the art
technology that existed out there
and then they advanced it a bit right
and they synthesized it in something
that is quite impressive from a
technology perspective it's quite
impressive because it's taken ideas like
a virtual machine for execution of smart
contracts and gas from aetherium our
Merkel state tree vats can be added to
Merkel mountain ranges or the etherium
state tree and embedded or intrinsic
digital currency similar to Bitcoin a
proof of all Authority federated network
of validators kind of similar to ripple
or AOS or a few of the other things that
are kind of block chains but not quite
and a new consensus algorithm that is
not exactly new it's a Byzantine fault
tolerant consensus algorithm which is
not proof of work but they say they want
to move it to proof of stake so some
very interesting stuff there and they
mashed all of this together and created
something that is very impressive from a
technology perspective and the reason
it's very impressive is because of who
did it not because what was done like if
I had released that white paper was 30
collaborators everybody would have been
like okay there's another blockchain but
when a company that has two billion
users does that people understand that
this could have a very very big impact
so the next thing that happens is we see
whether this survives first contact with
Facebook corporate because at the moment
this is an incubated project
it's idealistic it's progressive its
aggressive in its vision it is focus on
being decentralized a bit now and even
more in the future a bit permission now
permissionless in the future proof of
authority now proof of stake in the
future a very progressive aggressive
vision and that vision is going to run
straight into a whole bunch of MBAs and
lawyers at Facebook headquarters so
we're going to go wolf
or maybe not
let's see it's gonna be really
interesting to see how much of this
vision survives into deployment and
that's going to determine a lot of what
happens next and then even if it
survives into deployment at some point
this is going to potentially become very
successful very successful and a huge
moneymaker and then the MBAs are gonna
get very excited right there are some
things of the white paper that are quite
surprising for example the use of an
association to segregate it from
facebook a promise to not use the
profile information on your Facebook
account you have a Facebook account I
sure as hell don't the information
that's in your Facebook profile and use
that in collaboration with the currency
that's a no-no right and and so at the
moment it says that information is not
going to be shared it's not going to be
used for surveillance it's not going to
be used for any of these con oh one
second sorry yes we are sending you this
very important email to notify you of
changes to our terms of conditions
please read the following 600 pages of
gibberish to understand how we
completely removed you process in any of
your privacy thank you very much the
Facebook team okay so that email just
came to me from the future it was
written by an MBA and it's gonna change
all of those promises the moment this
becomes successful
you think I'm kidding look what happened
to whatsapp right look what happened to
whatsapp the founders of that company
that started with the same kind of a
deal idealistic vision left for going
hundreds of millions of dollars in pays
and bonuses and then said Hughes signal
used signal do not use whatsapp if
you're an if you're a dissident if
you're an activist if you're a political
operative if you're communication
confidentiality is going to make the
difference between you surviving or not
which means if you're any one of the
millions of people who march in hong
kong this week
yeah you signal don't use whatsapp will
something similar happen I'm a bit of a
cynic I think that large corporations
have a tendency to swallow innovation
and rip out all of the disruptive things
and spit out something that is neutered
and profit-making
and exploits their users because that's
their obligation their obligation is to
shareholders but we'll see maybe it
won't be so that's what happened on the
technical front this morning and now
everybody's trying to solve what I call
the three-body problem which is until
now we were looking at this space as the
interaction between two major forces on
one side we have governments
nation-states money fiat as we
derisively call it in the crypto space
and on the other side we have the
people's money right open borderless
cryptocurrency that's free for everyone
to use and these two forces are orbiting
each other and exerting pressure on each
other right now
you know crypto is a tiny little speck
of an asteroids right and fiat is a nice
big planet full of very very successful
life forms and those life forms are
looking up at the sky and going what's
that shiny thing it seems to be getting
bigger you know the experience of the
dinosaurs it's like don't worry pretty
look at how how nice the sunset looks it
keeps getting bigger
solving the two-body problem and trying
to figure out from a political
perspective what happens when
nation-states and open crypto currencies
collide is difficult enough
we can't tell because different nations
are positioning themselves in different
ways
some are freaked out by it and they ban
it outright
China's bandits 1726 times so far all
and effectively India's banded well kind
of twice right
Equador was one of the first to ban it
and just like completely and yet in many
advanced nations cryptocurrency has
actually been thriving many of what we
call free societies the idea of banning
a form of private currency is
constitutionally problematic right so
both the United States Constitution as
well as the United Kingdom's
Constitution protect freedom oh wait oh
yeah you don't have one but anyway the
Magna Carta let's say protects freedom
of speech and and money is a form of
political speech so that's something
that's cherished in free societies it's
not so easy to ban this thing so there's
a lot of this tension this morning that
was a big discussion on Twitter that I
reluctantly got involved in which is
about whether Facebook or whether
Facebook's Libre is a cryptocurrency or
not all right let's take a quick poll
all those who say it is a cryptocurrency
all those who say it's not a
cryptocurrency all those who haven't
decided yet that's okay
well turns out I don't think that
question really makes sense and the
reason it doesn't make sense is because
Facebook's Libre is a new thing it's a
corporate currency it's a corporate
digital currency and we haven't seen
corporate digital currencies since the
opium wars we haven't seen corporate
digital currencies since medieval
feudalism and the Medici right so how
how fitting how fitting that on the dawn
of corporate neo feudalism one of the
leading neo feudalist
corporate states super states of
corporations Facebook the nation of
Facebook the super nation of Facebook is
launching its own currency and things
are going to get very interesting now
they're going to get very interesting
for a number
reasons but the main reason is that we
now have a three-point standoff it is
now
money of the Corporations money of the
people and money of government all three
will exist none of them are going away
in fact there will be more joining the
doors been opened Facebook is the first
of the fangs the rest of them are baring
their fangs and ready to go
fangs if you don't know is Facebook
Amazon Netflix and Google the billion
dollar tech companies of Silicon Valley
but it's not just them because it's also
Twitter and uber and airbnb the era of
internet currencies just opens in
Silicon Valley is coming for the banks
in a way that's never happened before
now the bankers have been very very
comfortable until now I went to a
conference in Zurich speaking to banking
executives in 2014 and I told them
listen instead of hiring blockchain
consultants to tell you how to square
the circle and undisrupted disruption
and pretend to do blockchain you should
hire a former music executive from the
music industry and ask them what did it
feel like when the internet came for
your industry when did you realize that
you couldn't do anything about it and
how did you feel when you started losing
your entire industry to Apple and guess
what the banks had 10 years to figure
this [ __ ] out they had 10 years to try
to figure out how they're going to
handle digital currencies gen just like
the music industry should have made a
deal with Napster and instead they
fought it tooth and nail and handed the
entire industry to Apple the banking
industry should have made a deal with
Bitcoin
it was the cuddly little gecko of crypto
currencies and Facebook is a freaking
tart Triceratops and it's coming for
their industry this is going to disrupt
a lot of things
the really weird thing about it is that
the first to be affected by this are
retail banks retail banks not the big
bad investment banks that make shady
deals to bail out dictators and stuff
like that the banks that actually serve
customers most of the big investment
banks have stopped taking checking and
savings customers from the consumer
cycle for the last four or five years
they don't love that view people don't
pay enough right not worthy of banking
but retail banks the corner bank the
branch where you know the banker or at
least you know them every time you have
to go and discuss why your overdraft is
ballooning again but those retail banks
that actually serve customers that have
been delivering banking to the unbanked
and underbanked gradually expanding
their reach they're going to get hit
hard by this new phenomenon they're
going to get hit hard by Facebook
because Facebook has not only 2 billion
users but 2 billion users of whom they
know all of their preferences all of the
behavior patterns and they can use that
to drop the cost of banking wrap it in a
candy colored cute user interface so
that every time you make a purchase the
application jumps in and tickles your
dopamine receptors a bit and encourages
you to do certain things or not do other
things right and plays with you like a
little mouse in a psychology experiments
where you can't see that you're in the
maze because the walls are too high this
is going to be very very interesting as
it plays out but also to those of us
would be paying attention to the rise of
techno new feudalism it's terrifying
it's terrifying because Facebook is
going to be effective at disrupting
regulation in a way the banks have not
been able to it's terrifying because
among other things Facebook is now go
after central banks and yeah they have a
basket of currencies and they're going
to create some kind of stable coin thing
on this basket of currencies but that
stable coin is going to be stable visa v
your local currency that's hyper
inflating I talked about that this
morning the idea imagine you're in India
or Argentina and you're the government
and you want to follow an inflationary
devaluation policy and your population
has moved 10% of the economy on to Libre
and can take their savings and hide them
in the hard currency of Facebook it's
not really a hard card see it doesn't
really have a monetary policy or so they
say but it's harder than the Argentinian
peso it's harder than the Turkish lira
it's harder than the Indian rupee
it's harder than more than a hundred
currencies around the world and suddenly
the central banks have lost one of the
big levers of power they have over the
economy what are they going to do ban
Facebook shut down 10% of their economy
they're gonna try they're gonna try
exactly like they've been trying to ban
Facebook during protests and coos
dictatorships revolutions and they're
going to fail they're gonna try to
regulate Facebook imagine the poor
regulators who get paid like nothing in
their tweed suits academics from the
Economics Ministry facing an army of
Wall Street lawyers descending on their
tiny little country filling the parking
lot of the local airport with 17 Gulf
streams in a row and saying let's talk
about what we're going to do to your
economy if you didn't realize what
Facebook is planning on doing is
consumer retail level
sdrs who here knows what an SDR is a few
people yeah you get my meaning the
International Monetary Fund is a global
institution that's not controlled by
governments that uses
contributions of members that they put
in a basket of currencies to issue a
pseudo currency called Special Drawing
rights they're part of the international
framework of free floating exchange
rates and they are the lender of last
resort for governments and they do so in
a very predatory manner where they
impose extreme neoliberal austerity on
the government's that fall into their
clutches and they asset strip their
industries and their water plants and
their railroads and their
telecommunications companies well guess
what
Facebook's gonna do that now because if
you think about what Libre is it is a
Special Drawing rights pseudo currency
drawn on a basket of currency that is
funded directly by consumer activity in
the same countries where the government
is going to come back and ask them for a
loan or try to curtail their activity
this is very serious stuff
we just went post-national the power to
control money they used to be the
exclusive prerogative of the states
God's kicked in the nuts by Bitcoin and
decapitated by Libre this morning the
central bank control of a monetary
policy ended this morning because more
and more technology companies which
currently are worth a trillion dollars
once given the ability or taking the
ability to mint their own money will
radically transform their business
models would use that to generate more
money than you can ever imagine and very
very soon they will dwarf the GDP of at
least a third of the nation's on this
planet and when the IMF comes calling
most governments cower in fear but they
have no idea how much worse is going to
be when Facebook comes calling or Google
or Apple maybe even Twitter can take
down a few governments yeah it's big
enough why not pretty soon uber will be
dictating
not just to the taxi drivers but to the
local council to maybe even the
cabinet's of ministers we're looking at
a new world in which three forces are
going to be competing money of the
people money of the state and money of
the corporations that's a crossroads we
have to make some very careful choices
now I'm hopeful I'm hopeful for a number
of reasons I'm hopeful because they're
actually going to make a contribution to
the technology whether they want to or
not I'm hopeful because they're going to
introduce a billion people to the wrong
kind of cryptocurrency just like AOL
introduced almost a billion people to
the wrong kind of Internet and here's
where it gets tricky because at this
point we need to decide how we
differentiate our principles I've talked
about the fundamental principles that I
care about in blockchains
sometimes I call them the five pillars
sometimes I call them the eight criteria
I lose count all the time so it's
somewhere between five and eight but you
should always ask yourself about a
system that is trying to take over the
foundational technology of money in your
world is it open what does open mean is
it open so that anyone can access it
without vetting anyone can participate
in the network without vetting anyone
can send a transaction without providing
ID is it we don't know yet we'll see the
white paper is we'll see what the
currency actually does is it borderless
I can tell you right now it's not going
to be borderless there is only one
borderless global cryptocurrency of any
value and meaning today and that's big
and it's maybe as good at the as the US
dollar at being borderless but Facebook
is not going to be in China I can
guarantee you that libras not going to
launched in China because they're going
to have their own alternative that's
going to be launched by WeChat and it's
going to be a wholly owned subsidiary of
the People's Republic of China Central
politburo you know kind of like Facebook
is a wholly owned subsidiary of the NSA
and it's not going to launch in Russia
either because like hell are they going
to give up their monetary sovereignty to
a dude from Silicon Valley and it's not
going to launch in a bunch of other
places where there's a lot of unbanked
people who actually need this so it's
not going to be borderless in fact quite
the opposite
we've now entered the era of Cold War
currency wars the world is about to have
an Iron Curtain drop in currencies like
we've never seen before we're going to
see a fundamental split between East and
West in the evolution of state-based
currencies corporate based currencies
and open crypto currencies and of the
three only open crypto currencies go
everywhere it's probably not going to be
neutral neutrality requires the protocol
to allow transactions from anyone to
anyone for any purpose and a lot of open
crypto currencies do that I very much
doubt Libre can do that because the
moment they start doing that the
subpoenas will start flying and the most
important thing about a subpoena is
knowing where to serve it right and
that's easy they have an office which
accepts service of process and that's
where they're gonna send the subpoenas
where do you send the Bitcoin subpoenas
aha you can send them to 127 dot 0 dot 0
dot 1
come on / dance / null we will process
them immediately so it's not going to be
neutral it's not going to be sensitive
persistent because large corporations
like that that are bound by
jurisdictional regulations are obliged
under law to censor transactions you
cannot send a transaction on the network
like that to an Iranian to Venezuelan to
a North Korean or receive one from a
Russian or a Chinese citizen without
properly vetting who they are who their
parents are when they were born where
they live which companies they own who
they're related to this happens every
time you try to do a wire transfer
they're not going to be immutable they
say in the white paper they're immutable
the moment you have a transaction
they're that funded some abhorrent and
inexcusable activity on the open neutral
borderless Network subpoenas are gonna
start flying and the immutable network
is going to get muted pretty damn fast
pretty easy to do when you have a
consortium of validators with no cost to
modifying past history proof-of-work
actually makes it impossible even if a
hundred percent of the validators the
miners collude to go back and change the
history without expending the same
amount of energy which means that every
day that passes you're looking at an
energy cost that increases so fast that
very very quickly within a day or two
it's unapproachable
it's an undue burden it's almost
impossible even if you could find and
course all of the miners they wouldn't
be able to do it it's not won't its cans
and cans is much better than water so
it's not going to be immutable it might
be audible and transparent we don't yet
know but it if it is auditable and
transparent it's not going to be private
which means that we are probably only a
few years
launched before there's a giant freakin
leak and all of your financial data are
belong to us again right because if it's
in the blockchain and it's stored in a
transparent manner and you don't have
any privacy controls you know the kind
of criminals use at least they're smart
about using privacy well then what's
going to happen is all of that
information will be leaked so all of
your purchases will now be visible to
all of your friends and family and you
know we probably all have a very good
friend who we've made a pact with that
says look if I get hit by a bus I need
you to get my laptop I need you to erase
my browsing history and I need you to
shred all of my bank statements before
my mom gets to the house oh we we good
you know what I mean because financial
privacy is a human right society doesn't
work as a panopticon we have secrets
because we're social animals we have
secrets because that gives us the
freedom to express our freaky nature
because we all differ a bit from the
expectations and conformities of society
or at least I [ __ ] hope we do because
if we don't if we don't what kind of
society is that where you have to
absolutely conform to all of the
expectations of your stuck-up neighbors
right individuality expression freedom
is privacy and so we don't want our
financial records blast it to the
world's but that's what's gonna happen
next so it's gonna be audible and
transparent maybe but not very private
this is not the kind of blockchain that
I'm interested in but more importantly
once again as I've said many times
before we stand at a fork in the road
because on the one hand we have
surveillance money and on the other hand
we have free open and try
at people's money and guess what's gonna
happen with this new currency the path
to cash flow societies the timetable for
cashless societies just got accelerated
and cashless societies are nothing to
celebrate cashless societies are
societies without freedom our societies
without democracy our societies without
robustness fragile societies without the
possibility of an exit plan or of a
relief valve their societies in which
one election is the last election you
just have to get it wrong once you just
have to stay at home and say I don't
care about politics and all of the kooky
old people go out and they vote for an
orange man or brexit or some [ __ ] like
that and then you're like what the hell
happened but in a world in which you
don't have cash it's much worse than
that because now the government the
corporation the payment processor can
decide that you did something bad and
turn off your financial future make it
so that you can't even buy food let
alone pay your rent or your heating you
think this isn't happening it's
happening right now in Hong Kong it's
happening right now in China with a
sesame credit score system and if you
think it's not coming to a country like
yours study up on European history 1918
through 1945 fascinating [ __ ] we thought
the UK to learn that lesson for what I
mean seeing lately trying to repeat all
of those great sometimes you have to
teach the lesson twice and what are we
going to do in the crypto space we're
gonna start differentiating expect over
the next couple of years for a lot of
the crypto projects to get very very
focused about what their principles are
and how they differentiate now that
there's a lot of confusion now that
we're dealing with the 18 dimensional
partial differential equation of a three
body problem Oh everything's pulling on
everything else
in six degrees of freedom it's very
complicated who knows what happens next
look Facebook went into India uh India
wants to devalue some of the Indian
people are gone for crypto others are
being blocked what happens next
nobody knows it's going to get very
complicated so if you're in a curtal
project you need to decide what your
principles are it's interesting because
I've been expressing the same consistent
principles for the last seven years
thank you
the reason is really simple it takes too
much bloody homework to come up with
other ideas and try to remember how to
be consistent with what I said before if
I'm not following what I actually
believe it some people are an industry
noticed that recently inconsistencies
happen very very quickly some projects
within crypto recently faced that kind
of fork in the road and they decided to
focus on different principles to try to
change the trajectory of some of the
projects we care about right I've been
hearing lately one of these projects is
all about payment systems very very
inexpensive cheap payments at the
expense of decentralization and privacy
apparently to the people who are
following this is only useful for
illegal criminal money launderers who
are trying to support washe trading and
bucket shops now if that's the road you
want to go down that light you see is
not the light at the end of the tunnel
that's an oncoming Facebook train that
already has the principal less privacy
less markets staked out only they
already have two billion users lots of
money and lots of Technology people who
are going to run right over you if you
haven't differentiated based on your
principles or worse you don't have any
principles or you decided because you
recently hired an MBA who's really
interested in shareholder return on
investment that the best way to do that
would be to shed a few of these silly
idealistic principles that these
engineer dudes
or women have decided to support then
guess what you start shedding principles
and now you're facing Facebook and what
is Facebook if not the world's most
awesome principle shedding machine that
started with very few and then has
developed a mechanism for shedding them
faster than you can imagine with
billions of dollars of marketing
tickling your dopamine receptors telling
you don't worry the future is candy
colored and bright as long as we're
still profitable they can shed
principles faster than you with more
money than you with better user
interfaces than you and with a bigger
user base than you so if your game is
shed principles to make profit that's
the game you're not gonna win at
Facebook is gonna win that game and
they're gonna win it over PayPal they're
gonna win it over JPMorgan Chase and
they sure as hell gonna win it over a
little ragtag crypto project that said
we don't need privacy we want to be a
fast payment network that collaborates
with law enforcement and gives out
information for surveillance companies
for everyone to share figure out what
your principles are everybody is now
going to have to stop take a breath and
figure out how to differentiate and it's
actually pretty easy it's really really
easy if you're going to get into a fight
with someone who doesn't know how to
hold principles if you're going to get
into a fight with a corporation that is
not immoral because that requires having
negative morality but a moral which
means no moral guidance whatsoever a
lack of any moral compass because
morality doesn't even enter the equation
morality is not on the spreadsheet
morality did not enter the ROI equation
if you're going to enter fight with them
differentiate on the thing they can't
compete with make yourself the one
project
or align yourself with the one project
that is truly open borderless neutral
censorship resistance transparent
auditable private immutable and there
are a few of those I think I expect the
privacy currencies are going to get
quite a run because now suddenly there's
a reason to really focus on privacy and
that's because Facebook won't so things
just got really interesting as a
technologist I am so excited I've been
jumping up and down all day I can't wait
to see how this plays out because that's
been my lifelong fascination watching
technological systems interact with
society and change the world and watch
these developments roll out and see if I
can pick up a few clues as to where
these things are going to have that
vision that's been my life's goal as a
technologist I've been jumping up and
down as a human being I am horrified I'm
horrified at the fact that we are about
to open the door to a future that is
truly dystopian that is truly terrifying
and give an amount of power to some of
the most ruthless unaccountable
corporations out there to not just fight
against government but in many cases
join hand-in-hand in making sure that
while we're exploited by ruthless
politicians on one side were exploited
by ruthless businesspeople on the other
an unholy alliance between capital
Corporation and state is called fascism
only this isn't your Grandpa's fascism
this is a whole new neo feudal
environment that we have never seen
before and a lot of people are going to
make the fundamental mistake of thinking
that because it doesn't come in the
leather uniform designs
a fantastic German designer Hugo Boss
right with clashing colors and
caricatures parades and screaming into
megaphones
and with all of the symbolism of that
it's not fascism fascism today comes in
a slick user interface in beautiful
colors accessible 24/7 through a browser
at your most convenient location on your
phone 24/7 whether your phone is on or
off and it is part of your life it's
what connects you to Grandpa and allows
you to share photos with Grandpa that
same grandpa who fought Nazis it's the
ultimate irony we need to be very
careful about what we do next this is
deadly serious stuff society is not
ready for this because we've never been
here before and while I am fascinated to
watch at the same time I'm deeply
troubled
I'm not afraid because I don't think
Bitcoin can compete I'm afraid because I
believe that a lot of people don't care
a lot of people will go for the easy the
convenient the mindless the repetitive
the seductive the hypnotizing rhythm of
a Facebook feed and they will lose their
freedom and their future thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you